hi everyone so my name is Lis and I
previously co-founded argon which is the
largest platform for decentralized
autonomous organization help in this
communities govern more than 20 billion
do in ater
management and the first time I came
through uh through Bitcoin I thought oh
we have sering money then I went down to
uh co-found Aragon um and then we have
servering organizations and now um
working on the next step uh which is
kind of like Sovereign individuals and
so allowing everyone to be a sovereign
individual so I'm going to talk about
sovereignty through citizenship and
basically why you should add a passport
or see a passport as part of your uh
sovereignty
stack so basically what we're doing at
Bas flow uh the company that I'm working
on now is we are creating the smoothest
way to get a second passport and so I'm
going to come into uh in a minute in um
how how and which countries uh welcome
people like like you that are talented
uh and and that want to be part of this
forward looking countries but let's go
into a bit of the perks of having these
multiple passports so first of all um
you have access to your opportunities uh
you can leave new places you can go to
conferences like this one uh you can you
know go to the Caribbean for some
tourism and ler uh and also family
reunification which has been quite
important in coid times because I mean
there were so many drama dramatic
stories of people just getting SE ated
because of different passport
nationalities families were broken
relationships that might have happened
never happened um all because of
passports and uh and not having enough
of them there are multiple risks of
having just one passport and so one of
them is lot of Mobility we don't think
about this often for example I'm
Spaniard and now the Spanish passport is
great but we don't know 20 years from
now or 10 years from now these things do
change back in the day people from Spain
were going to Venezuela to work uh into
Argentina because it was prosperous
prosperous countries now it's exactly
the opposite in only like a few decades
so these things do change then you have
exit taxes so some countries treade you
like cattle and when you want to leave
well you got to pay a price so that's
also a big problem you have military
mobilization which I included here
because um I I know firsthand having
some Ukrainian family that it happens
and so some some friends of uh some of
my family um were only not you know
living in Bankers for some time but also
had to suddenly you know uh go to go to
war and and it happens these things do
happen and the other thing is worldwide
taxation which I'll go into into it a
little bit but yeah again some countries
treating citizenships like cattle
instead of
customers so basically like you don't
want to have all your eggs in the same
basket especially if you are into crypto
uh if you're into sobering money if
you're into sovereignty we are all quite
paranoid we want to live our life we
don't want anyone to disturb us we want
to do our thing have our Ventures our
family um you know build your wealth
over time and the truth is right now the
changes in macro policy can make this
quite
challenging and um basically you can
actually rank passports so you can think
of this the coin market cap uh or Co Geo
of of passports and so this is based on
like Mobility so how many countries you
can travel to political stability of the
country obviously no worldwide taxation
that's where the US Passport is not as
great as it might seem to some uh and OB
family or children rights can you can
your children actually inherit this
passport um so to say so for example
what do the US and Eritrea have in
common why the different countries well
these two countries do uh do tax you
worldwide so even if you go to like you
know the UK and have a different non-one
regime in which you can pay less taxes
during 105 years you know they don't
care you're are going to still pay taxes
to the US um and and that's quite
mind-blowing but again it does happen
the US is quite an important country in
the world so who tells that tomorrow
we're not going to have other countries
follow suit and start doing the same so
basically if you want to acquire new
citizenship um if you're really as I say
the platform is quite hard so basically
what I'm trying to say is if you're
stateless you cannot you know it's quite
kind of hard to get a new citizenship um
but if even you have a citizenship of a
country today it's still quite hard
because it's a very bureaucratic process
really bureaucratic process here's like
a form well not a form but like a list
of forms that you need to fill and with
PDFs and emails and what and then these
documents get leaked on the internet
because of like some not very like maybe
best security practices and then your
home address gets leaked on the internet
again and then you have to move homes
you know these things do happen and also
renouncing citizenship is quite um
cumbersome as well and sometimes it does
incur in exit taxes uh this again um in
they have this in the US and uh also in
other countries like European countries
and it's becoming more and more
generalized that you have to pay exit
taxes sometimes you even have to sell
everything you have to realize the gains
pay the taxes and then you figure out
what to do with your asset later but
it's it's quite quite dramatic so let's
talk about citizenship versus residency
so uh if you're a passport freak like me
I mean that Swiss passport is a sexy
passport just look at it it's so
beautiful um and I hope that we can have
many passports more like this that pop
up of countries that are appearing here
today and you know they give you
governance rights so you can vote uh
they give you Mobility if you're a
resident you might have some Mobility
but if you have passport then you can
just access countries Visa free all over
the world um the user residency is easy
to revoke maybe on basis of employment
or marriage or whatever citizenship is
quite hard to revoke and obviously
family rights um so you like usually
don't pass down uh or to your family
like residency but it is the case
usually with citizenship one interesting
thing here is the new models of
citizenship so you can think of
citizenship in the old world and in the
new world and so basically um the
there's like by Blood and so basically
that means you know if your parents had
a passport then you probably have a
passport or bir right so basically you
were born in a country you got a
passport the latter is much uh more
common in in the new world and so you
can think about the US Canada um and so
forth that welcome a lot of migrants and
then basically like that that was a way
of welcoming migrants as compared to
like you only have a a passport if you
are like you know at the stent of
someone else that have a passport the
interesting thing is uh this new model
that have popped up the last new decades
and that is the citizens in by
investment so there are countries um
like you know countries that are already
kind of like recognized and well known
and some of them are in quite nice
places like the Caribbean which is you
know uh as we've explored today
beautiful beautiful Waters crystalling
Waters uh PR connected to the US and so
forth and so they welcome foreign
investors that want to be part of a
citizen base so for 100k you can
basically uh get into get a get to be a
citizen of these countries um 125k you
can start including your family and this
again is something that you pass down so
it's you can think about it as something
that like you know some kind of like
generational wealth that you pass down
to your family and I think this is very
important because in the sovereignty
stack as I was talking before there is
Sovereign money so that's
cryptocurrencies there is citizenships
so you can hch your bets and kind of
like be above these nation states um
there's companies which you can have in
different places in the world um and
then there is also residency so ideally
you want to have all of these in
different places all across the globe
right now this might seem that it can
only apply to a very small percentage of
the population but I do believe that
we're getting into a direction in which
you know a few years maybe decades from
now everyone just will look at this as
their kind of like citizenship stack and
so maybe when you are 18 years old you
are starting to pick like you know uh
not only what you want to study and work
on or maybe you don't want to study and
you want to drop out or and like join
this new kind of like ways of Education
uh but then you also might pick your
country or or countries even and like
where do you have your company and where
do you have your residency and which
passport are you going to pass down to
your children and so forth and so on and
this is very liberating because we are
switching from like being cattle
controlled by uh you know some
governments here and there to being
something else that is like a little bit
above above those and going where you
are treated best and inviting these
governments to actually treat you really
well and believe me some governments do
want to treat people exctly people like
us here that are like talented very well
and they are willing to do so we just
need to work with them um sometimes to
create new cities and sometimes to just
move to to these countries or even
create new States within these countries
as we seen
today so basically I would invite you
all to think of passports as a Mobility
platform um so it's not only something
that is like an annoying piece of paper
that you like carry around uh and and
that sometimes is beautiful like the
Swiss one but also it's a Mobility
platform it does enable you to do things
you then be able to do otherwise and we
sometimes again think that nothing is
going to change because we think about
our country and the fact that it's may
be great for the last 10 years 20 but
mro has changed very quickly right now
so it's really good to be
prepared so um at Bas flow we streamline
in this process uh we are inite only
right now but if you scan this code it
will take you to a a page that we built
um for this conference and we'll try to
basically just like uh jump you through
through some of the queue and and get
Early Access
the the last thing I was in Amsterdam
for a work conference was actually 10
years ago and it was called the Bitcoin
conference and I remember Brian
Armstrong was giving out coin best
flyers and I will say the vi here today
reminds me so much of that conference in
2013 and so I think 10 years from now
we're going to look back at this and be
like wow that ignited a movement so
thank you so
much